so today's video is not actually a
regular by graphics video if you watch
regularly we all know that we don't
usually put out videos on a Friday so
this is entirely bonus content and in
this one we're looking at a guy called
Alexis and Martin but here's the thing
this actually aired on another channel
that I recently launched its called
highlight history this one just happens
to be in a particular biography style so
I thought it would be a good chance to
promote this channel on biographic so if
you subscribe to that channel and you've
seen this already then I apologize you
do also don't have to go over to the
channel I'm gonna play the full video
for you today because I get really
frustrated around it's like hey here's
five minutes from my new channel and
then you have to go over and watch the
rest on the new channel it's all here
you can just watch it and enjoy it you
don't have to go and subscribe if you
don't want to it would be cool if you
enjoyed it if you did no pressure
enjoy the video oh and there's a link
below if you do want to subscribe
getting shot in the stomach not exactly
conductive to keeping on living a fact
that makes the story of Alexi some more
talk all the more impressive and by the
way this guy is french-canadian his name
is like Sam Otto or something but I'm
not gonna try and slice his name in in
French pronunciation all the time so I'm
just gonna go with some Martin and now
it's not exactly 100% accurate but it is
a hundred percent more easy so he got
shot in this organ at the age of 20 on
June the 6th 1822 at a range of less
than a meter despite this he went on and
lived for another half century despite
the wounds never completely healing this
gave scientists an almost literal window
into how the body digests its food so
how did this all come about well Martin
was an illiterate french-canadian
indentured servant working as a fur
trapper for the American Fur Company he
was shot in the gut by a fellow trapper
at the Mackinac Island Trading Post what
exactly happens here isn't clear but
it's largely agreed that the whole thing
was pretty much just an unfortunate
accident caused by the fellow trapper
accidentally discharging his weapon
within half an hour the resident army
physician stations at Mackinac Islands
dr. William Beaumont was looking over
some Martin and
you might imagine what he saw wasn't
exactly pretty he stated the dark shot
entered posteriorly and in an oblique
Direction forward and inward literally
blowing off into garments and muscles of
the size of a man's hands fracturing and
carrying away the anterior half of the
sixth rib fracturing the fifth
lacerating the lower portion of the left
lobe of the lungs the diaphragm and
perforating the stomach the whole mass
of materials forced from the musket
together with fragments of clothing and
pieces of fracturing ribs were driven
into the muscle and cavity of the chest
found a portion of the lungs as large as
a Turkey's egg protruding through the
external wounds lacerated and burnt and
immediately below there's another
protrusion which on further examination
proved to be a portion of the stomach
lacerated through all its coats and
pouring out the food he had taken for
his breakfast through an orifice large
enough to admit the forefinger all right
so as you might imagine from all of this
and lacking modern surgery Beaumont saw
little hope that something Martin would
make it through the night however he
operated as best he could anyway and
against all expectations the man
actually survived a problem arose
however when attempts were made for Sam
Martin to eat and drink
you see thanks to the gaping hole in his
stomach anything swallowed ultimately
just ended up gushing right out of the
hole in his side undeterred the
enterprising Beaumont simply has spent
weeks feeding some Martin via nutrias
enemas and this little bit of innovation
it actually totally works after a few
weeks Beaumont reported that rectal
feedings became unnecessary
despite the hole in the stark remaining
they got around the problem via applying
compressors and adhesive straps to some
Martin so as to obtain his food
remarkably Beaumont also notes no
sickness nor unusual irritation of the
stomach not even the slightest nausea
was manifest during the whole time and
after the fourth week the appetite
became good digestion regular the
evacuations natural and all the
functions of the system
perfect and natural after five weeks and
Martin was healing nicely and most
everywhere it
that troublesome hole in his stomach
rather than healing naturally it has
become more or less attached to the hole
in his skin forming something of a
sphincter with a slight prolapse of the
stomach pushing through it because of
this continued application of
compressors was needed for some Martin
to retain any food and drink
a month later Beaumont was still
attempting various sometimes very
painful means to get the wound to close
itself with unfortunately no success he
then started cutting the stomach away
from the skin and attempting to suture
everything back up but at this point
some Martin had simply had enough
otherwise mostly healthy and fully
functional other than you know the
literal hole in his stomach and abdomen
he refused any surgery in the interim of
all this Martin was released from his
indentured servitude contract and booted
out of the hospital as he had no money
to pay Beaumont's however saw a golden
opportunity in some martin to study the
human digestive tract of close and
personal and we mean really personal for
example at one point he literally stuck
his tongue in the hole noting on
applying the tongue to the mucous coat
of the stomach in its mg on irritated
state no acid taste can be perceived so
up to this point in history not really
much was known about how the human
digestive tracts actually worked doctors
in the past there experimented on
animals but this pretty much inevitably
always led to the animals death so
observing a working digestive tract was
never really feasible also dissecting
human bodies absolutely was a thing but
again it's not really helpful in
observing the process of digestion
happening in a living organism to work
out ways around this some doctors had
tried various things like tying strings
to mesh bags filled with food items and
then swallowing them waiting for some
period and then pulling the item back up
through the mouth but nobody ever had a
scent Martin to play with as such
Beaumont offered to sign Martin on as an
indentured servant to himself primarily
working as a laborer for Beaumont but
also with the agreement that Beaumont
would be able to experiment on him in
pretty much any way he wanted
now that original contract was lost to
history so they don't know the terms of
that one but one he later signed does
remain and in that new one it basically
says that in return for Beaumont being a
guinea pig and his servant beau
would cover some Martin's room and
boredom would also pay him $150 a year
which is about $2,800 today after a few
years of this Sint Maarten broke his
contract and left without permission
heading up to Canada where he started a
family perturbs but nonetheless still
wanting to study some Martin Beaumont
spent a considerable sum of money
tracking Sint Maarten down and then
convincing the fur company it's in
Martin was then working for to allow him
to return he then offered some Martin
things like a huge increase in pay land
granted by the government and money to
relocate his family or better yet even
more money to abandon his wife and kids
however privately he darkly wrote when I
get him alone again into my keeping I
will take good care to control him as I
please may also variously referred to
some Martin's children in a letter as
livestock and another to the US Surgeon
General lamented Sint Maartens
villainous obstinacy and ugliness they
arms all this when writing about Sint
Maarten he generally referred to him as
boy rather than calling him by his name
but before all of that with lapses here
and there due to the aforementioned
instances of Sir Martin fleeing the
doctors not so tender care Beaumont
basically spent his time dropping or
shoving random things in toussant
Martin's stomach do you see what happens
oh and we really do mean see here
because he would often force the whole
open so he'd get a good look of what
would happen to you food and drink once
he put it in there oh I'm beyond
sticking his tongue in the wound he also
occasionally would extract things
including stomach tissue and food items
on the Lasser after extraction he even
sometimes taste-tested them for instance
at one point writing the partially
digested chicken tasted bland and sweet
Beaumont also spent considerable time
extracting stomach acids to then
experiment with separately including
sending samples around to other doctors
who were looking to do experiments as do
this uncomfortable procedure he wrote on
introducing the tube the fluids soon
begins to flow first by drops then in an
interrupted and sometimes in a short
continuous stream moving the tube about
up and down or backwards and forwards
increases the discharge the quantity of
fluid ordinarily obtained is from four
dragons to one and a half or two ounces
its extraction is generally attended by
that peculiar sensation at the pit of
the stomach termed sinking with some
degree of faintness which
renders it necessary to stop the
operation the usual time of extracting
the juices early in the morning before
he is eaten when the stomach is empty
and clean
fascinatingly despite the wounds never
heal embalmer did report a rather odd
occurrence that happens about a year and
a half after the initial injury at this
time a small fold or doubling of the
coats of the stomach appeared at the
superior margin of the orifice slightly
protruding and increasing till it filled
the aperture so as to supersede the
necessity for the compress and bandage
for retaining the contents of the
stomach this valvular formation adapted
itself to the accidental orifice as to
completely prevent the flux of the
gastric contents when the stomach was
full thus while the hole in sir Martin
stomach and abdomen still persisted an
effective sphincter of sorts made up of
stomach tissue formed to allow --scent
Martin to no longer necessarily need a
wrap to keep the contents of his stomach
from simply falling out in any events
the various discoveries very well made
over the course of years experimenting
on some martin ultimately saw him named
the father of gastric physiology and
helped him lay the groundwork of our
modern understanding of the human
digestive process amazingly Sir Martin
actually lived to the ripe old age of 78
firing six children and otherwise living
a pretty normal if mostly impoverished
life as for after while inquiries were
made by doctors to you a quarte ins body
when he died his family had anticipated
this reportedly leaving his body out in
the Sun for a time until it was quite
decomposed and then burying him in a
secret location to avoid any chance
anyone would dig him up and perform an
autopsy as two specific inquiries one
doctor boldly sent a medical bag for
some Martin's family to mail the stomach
back in instead they simply replied with
a telegram stating don't come for
autopsy will be killed